massive pro-freedom demonstrations break
out in cuba
the united states continues its
ill-advised withdrawal from afghanistan
and kamala harris thinks rural people
don't have photocopiers i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn you have a right to privacy
defend your rights at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first here is your reminder
look at that cell phone bill you're
spending way too much money on it if
you're with verizon or att or t-mobile
you're paying
too much pure talk and save your family
over 800 a year
you get the same great coverage because
pure talk is on the exact same network
as one of the big three but at a
fraction of the price and switching
is as easy as switching out your sim
card you can keep your phone keep your
number or get huge discounts on the
latest iphones and androids plus
right now you can get unlimited talk
text and six gigs of data for just 30
bucks a month and
if you go over on data they're not going
to charge you for it there's a reason
pure talk is the highest rated wireless
company by consumer affairs and why they
are the preferred wireless partner
of amac from your cell phone now pound
250 say ben shapiro
and you will save an additional 50 off
your very first month of coverage that
is pound 2 5
0 say ben shapiro here's the thing
you've been using one of those big
wireless carriers because pretty much
everybody does
these days but here is the thing they
are not telling you what it is that you
are getting you have no idea what
exactly your cell phone bill actually
covers pure talk usa is absolutely
transparent unlimited talk text six gigs
of data for 30 bucks a month and again
if you go over they're not going to
charge you for it so what exactly are
you waiting for switch over
use my special code dial pound 250 say
my name ben shapiro save an additional
off your very first month by switching
over to puretalk usa
alrighty so at long last there is a
an actual on the ground revolution
going on in cuba it's being described as
unprecedented by nearly everybody who's
been watching cuban politics for the
last several decades we were talking
massive protests in the streets of this
totalitarian
dictatorship i had the opportunity just
a couple of weeks ago
to go down to miami and speak with many
of the leaders in the cuban dissident
movement to our expatriates here
in the united states and speak to some
of the dissidents on the island itself
actually during one of the
phone calls that i was holding with a
dissident in cuba
this this dissident he and i were
speaking about what exactly this is all
about
spoiler alert it was not just about
vaccines charges which as we'll see is
the media spin
on this thing it is about the brutal
communist dictatorship that has
repressed
nearly all personal freedom on the
island it is a cross-political movement
in cuba it is not just a bunch of sort
of reaganite right-wingers
it is it is it is everybody who wants to
see personal liberty win
the people who are leading this movement
have deliberately kept it apolitical
many of these people are artists who
have a left word bent on politics but
they understand the difference between
being left with regard to some economic
matters and also recognizing that you
have to have human freedom in any case
i was speaking with this dissident on
the phone and the cuban security
services cut off the call
with a pre-recorded message explaining
that the call had been cut off because
it violated security protocols
in cuba that is what kind of a country
cuba is that's what that regime is and
that's why it was so
evil frankly for the united states under
barack obama to try to make nice with
raul
castro those pictures of barack obama
holding hands with raul castro going to
baseball games
with raul castro standing in front of
giant buildings
with emblems of che guevara one of the
great mass murderers of the 20th century
behind him it was a disgrace to the
united states
and unbecoming of any president of the
united states to participate in so far
the biden administration has been
completely silent
on all of this i've yet to see a
statement at least as of
monday morning from the biden
administration on protest that had been
rocking the island of cuba since
saturday according to the new york times
shouting freedom and anti
and other anti-government slogans which
by the way should tell you all you need
to know
about cuba if freedom is an
anti-government slogan
in cuba that says something about the
nature of the government
shouting freedom and anti and other
anti-government slogans thousands of
cubans took to the streets and cities
around the country on sunday to protest
food and medicine shortages in a
remarkable eruption of discontent not
seen
in nearly 30 years again this is a
deliberate misconstruction by the new
york times it is not just about food and
medicine shortages
cuba has had food and medicine shortages
for quite a while and by the way i was
reliably informed by all
of the international communities most
trusted sources that cuba
has one of the best medical systems on
the planet why should they have medicine
shortages
i was told that their nationalized
health care system by michael moore no
less no less a source than michael moore
he made an entire movie talking about
the wonders of the cuban healthcare
system
there shouldn't be i mean it's a
communist paradise there shouldn't be
any food or medicine shortages over
there that's not really what it's about
it's the fact that they have been
imprisoning dissidents they've been
imprisoning young artists they've been
imprisoning college students over there
thousands of people marched through san
antonio de las pagnos southwest of
havana with videos
streaming live on facebook for nearly an
hour before they suddenly disappeared
why why
why would they disappear this is a this
is a beautiful left-wing communist
dictatorship what is the problem
as the afternoon wore on other videos
appeared from demonstrations elsewhere
including
palma soriano in the country's southeast
hundreds of people also gathered in
havana itself
where a heavy police presence proceeded
their arrival people are dying of hunger
one woman shouted during a protest
filmed in the province of artemisa in
the islands west our children are dying
of hunger one clip circulating on
twitter showed protesters overturning a
police car in cardenas
90 miles east of havana another video
showed people looting from one of the
much detested government-run stores
which still wildly overpriced items and
currencies most cubans do not possess
because as it turns out
communism just sucks it's just terrible
and i know that bernie sanders had this
sort of warm feeling about breadlines
and i know that the democratic
socialists of america the folks like
alexander ocasio-cortez
who have never spent an instant living
under communist repression
have a very soft spot for communist
dictatorship i get it but
let's be real living under communist
dictatorship absolutely sucks
there's a reason that since the rise of
the
castro regime in the late 50s tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands of
people have fled the island
of cuba there's a reason why people will
take the risk of putting their children
on floating cars and attempting to float
to 90 miles from cuba
to the to the south tip of florida
there's a reason for that
as the new york times reports in a
country known for repressive crackdowns
on dissent the rallies were widely
viewed as astonishing
activists and analysts called it the
first time so many people had openly
protested against the communist
government
since the so-called malaconazole
uprising which exploded in the summer of
1994 into a huge wave of cubans leaving
the country by sea
and there is another sort of wave coming
is sort of the
widely expected response by the
government because the government either
is going to imprison everyone or beat up
everyone
or expel everyone and so the united
states should be ready to take in
cuban patriots who are attempting to
overthrow the repressive regime
that has condemned their country to
living in the 1950s
under zero freedom for literally three
generations at this point
carolina bararo a cuban activist went
even further she said it is the most
massive popular demonstration to protest
the government we've experienced in cuba
since 1959. she called the public
outpouring on sunday spontaneous frontal
and forceful she said what has happened
is enormous so what exactly is the new
york times take on this
is it absolutely predictable it's not
because of the cuban government you see
it's because of the west
it's because the west has been so mean
to cuba yes we've had an embargo on cuba
for 60 years
but it really is just because we're
embargoing them now under
it's donald trump's fault that all this
is happening otherwise everybody would
be super happy with the cuban regime
so terrible that people have been living
in abject poverty for three generations
and are still driving around 1955 chevys
the protests were set off by a dire
economic crisis in cuba where the
coronavirus pandemic has cut off
crucial tourism dollars people now spend
hours in line each day to buy basic food
items
many have been unable to work because
restaurants and other businesses have
remained on lockdown for months now
what's so weird about that
you may have noticed is that all we
heard from the american press is how
horrible america's response to the
coronavirus was because
we're a capitalist country oh our
capitalist institutions are failing oh
we need more state intervention
cuba is a completely state-run system
and it's a giant fail when it comes to
kovid
the desperate conditions have triggered
an uptick in migration by both land and
sea since the start of the fiscal year
last october the us coast guard has
intercepted more than 512 cubans at sea
compared with 49 for the entire previous
year on saturday the coast guard
suspended the search for nine cuban
migrants whose vessel overturned at sea
off key west florida again
the enormous risk that people take
simply attempting to
they literally take like buoys and then
just try to float themselves 90 miles
you know how horrific your living
conditions have to be
in order for you to try that would you
try that with your kids would you try
that that's how bad things are in cuba
and we've allowed that communist
dictatorship to stand for nion
60 years more than 60 years at this
point which is a disgrace to the united
states and disgrace to the western world
period that that regime is a disgrace to
the western world and the fact the
united states has allowed a tin pot
dictatorship to flourish
off its coast threatening america by the
way in the middle of the cold war
for for 60 years it just demonstrates
how little willing the united states
actually is
to project power get some more of this
in just one second
first let's talk for a second about you
know your energy levels i'm a busy dude
i write books host the show
raised three kids got a lot going on
that's why i recommend m drive the
everyday supplement for men driven to
stay ahead in their life and career who
wants to be the best at what they do
and not slow down while doing it m drive
gives you the energy to tackle your busy
days
and still be at your best when you go
home at night invented by a world-class
scientist who made it for himself to
fight back against aging m drive is
packed with clinically tested
ingredients that help
boost your energy and strength now
people around the office taking i'm
trying let me tell you
everybody's just got a little more pump
in their step get your m drive at
mdrive4men.com get 20
off your first order with promo code ben
they have free shipping and a 60 day
money back at guaranty so you can give
it a shot
it doesn't work for you you haven't lost
anything again they've got that free
shipping 60 day money back guarantee
energy strength drive join the growing
community of driven men who aren't ready
to slow down quite yet
go to m drive for men dot com promo code
ben again that's
mdrive4men.com promo code ben don't let
age
beat you refined your prime with m drive
again that's
m drive for men.com and use promo code
ben
go check them out right now okay so the
the american left has had a tough time
condemning what's been going on in cuba
this has been true for for decades
and the american left has always had a
bit of a soft spot for cuba it's just an
experimental regime you see american
leftists on college campuses wearing
t-shirts of che guevara as i mentioned
is a mass murderer and an evil piece of
human scum i was honored to meet one of
the men who helped capture him
just last month here in florida is a
pretty amazing experience
over at a museum for the uh the brigade
that fought in the bay pigs
it is amazing the contrast between the
cuban protesters
and the americans who don't like the
american flag so this just struck me
forcibly
last night one of the videos that was
coming out of cuba
was protesters and you'll notice that
one of the flags that they are carrying
around is the american flag
you can see it in this photo there they
are carrying around the american flag
and this this is not a shock
okay this is it they're shouting
libertad
cuba they're they're talking about
freedom
and they're carrying around american
flags because everywhere on earth that
you go where you find people who want
freedom
they are not carrying the flag of the
russians
or the chinese or the swedes or the
brits or the french or the germans they
are carrying the american flag and it is
not true
merely in cuba it is true in places like
hong kong there's footage from hong kong
you'll remember just before the chinese
crushed
the hong kong dissident movement you'll
recall that there were members
of the hong kong district movement and
they were carrying the american flag
that is not a shock again the the rule
is that if you are a dissident who seeks
freedom
america is your beacon the american flag
is your symbol
again here is the footage from just
about a year ago when hong kong
dissidents were marching in the streets
carrying the american flag
[Music]
there is a reason they are pushing the
american flag there's a reason they're
flying the american flag
again no other country has its flag
flown as a symbol of freedom around the
planet
none zero zip zilch again from cuba
to hong kong wherever communist tyranny
reigns those who stand up to it carry
the american flag not just communist
tyranny by the way in iran when you have
dissidents who are standing up to
islamic dictatorship
you will see that protesters dissidents
refuse to step on the american flag
this is an amazing video from just a
couple of years ago where dissidents
were protesting against the iranian
regime
and they were they were stepping around
the american flag the
iranian regime had painted the american
flag on the pavement and the dissidents
instead of disrespecting and walking on
the american flag decided to walk around
the american flag to demonstrate that
they were not anti-america they were
actually
pro-america i mean that's amazing stuff
right there
okay the contrast between that and the
number of americans who hate
and spit on the american flag is truly
astonishing and so i have a proposal
one for one trade every single dissident
who wants to fly the american flag and
believes in american freedom for all of
the americans who spit on the american
flag and see it as a symbol of
repression and evil
how about that will we make that trade
right now
now in reality american citizens can't
be expelled simply because they don't
like the flag because we do have freedom
of speech but in principle
the folks who are marching in cuba for
liberty right now and flying the
american flag are better americans than
the americans
who stand around spitting on the
american flag and pretending that it is
a symbol of repression and evil
you know who those people are people who
have never lived under true repression
and evil
seriously if you live under the threat
of true oppression and evil the american
flag is the symbol of liberty if you
live in america
a place of liberty we have this
ungrateful
rather despicable distaste for our own
freedom
we we've gotten so used to being fat and
lazy and rich and free
and we seem to forget that there are
people all over the planet who live like
that and that for most of human history
none of that was the rule and when you
see the contrast
between people in cuba who are risking
life and limb i mean the security
services are shooting people right now
there's video that was emerging from
cuba yesterday of the police in cuba
gunning down like firing live ammunition
according to these videos
at dissidents at protesters you can see
some of the videos
and it's a wonderful stuff happening
over there when you see that sort of
activity
by by actual repressive regimes and then
you have the united states
the left of the united states mainstream
going completely silent on it
while spitting on the american flag it
does tell you something because they
have been completely silent on it
the left simply has nothing to say about
the liberty of people in cuba and by the
way the people who are protesting in
cuba
would not i mean i met with many of them
many of them would not identify as
right-wing american republicans they
would not
many of them would identify i'm sure as
democrats they believe
in large social services they're not
people who nationally
who oppose naturally
for example nationalized healthcare they
might like nationalized health care but
what they understand
on a route level is that a government
that represses its people and abolishes
private property and cuts against profit
motive and decides that human beings
ought not have rights that pre-exist
government
will inevitably slip into tyranny that
they understand at a gut level
and meanwhile you have again the
sickening specter of americans
kneeling for the american flag while
living in the richest and freest country
in the history of the world
i promise you colin kaepernick would not
trade places with any one of these cuban
dissidents
i promise you ilhana omar would not be
trading places with any one of the
people living in hong kong right now
none of these people ever willing to put
their money where their mouth is when it
comes to ripping the united states and
talk about how evil it is
none of these folks actually believe
that the united states like i really
doubt the sincerity of many of these
folks or
if i don't doubt their sincerity i doubt
their knowledge level there's tremendous
level of ignorance
if if you never look outside the borders
of the united states it's very easy to
identify the problems of the united
states if you ever look
for five seconds outside the border of
the united states or beyond the time
period of today what you will see is
that the vast majority of history and
today in the vast majority of countries
the kind of liberties
that we expect that we demand from our
government are not available to the vast
majority of people which is why those
people marched with our flag while we
in here in the united states are giving
millions of dollars
to athletes who just stain the american
flag
and yes flags stand for something you
know who knows that the people who are
marching with our flag
in cuba right now at risk to their own
life and limb
meanwhile the way that the biden
administration is downplaying this so
far
is truly an amazing thing it's truly an
astonishing thing
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about improving
your business podium makes doing
business as easy as sending a text
because when texts get opened
business gets done all your employees
can text from a single inbox offering a
smoother experience for your customers
if you're answering questions you should
send a text if you're collecting reviews
you can send a text
scheduling an appointment or delivery
send a text payment collection just send
a text text is just the easiest thing
have you ever gotten like a telemarketer
or call have you ever picked up has that
ever sold you on anything the answer is
no but if you run a business
and you send somebody a text there's a
really good shot they return the text
because it's quick
and it's easy and it's convenient card
dealerships are selling more cars by
offering
text messages a dealer just sold a 50
000 truck in four text messages for
example retailers are increasing revenue
by allowing customers to shop
via text message a jeweler just sold a 5
000 ring with a few text messages
and even coordinated curbside pickup
with podium so if you run a business and
you're not taking advantage of the
texting revolution you're missing out
right now
go check out podium stay ahead of your
competition with podium they have free
plans
for growing businesses plus all the
power growing businesses need
to scale get started today at podium.com
shapiro again that is podium.com
shapiro that's podium.com shapiro
go check them out right now so here is
it
it really is an amazing thing here is
what the
acting assistant secretary for u.s
department of state's bureau of western
hemisphere affairs tweeted out and this
so far is the only statement that i've
been able to find from the
white house of joe biden quote peaceful
protests are growing in cuba as the
cuban people exercise their right to
peaceful assembly to express concern
about rising covet cases deaths and
medicine shortages
we commend the numerous efforts of the
cuban people mobilizing donations to
help neighbors in need
oh so you're just going to completely
miss the point there so there are a few
things about this tweet that are truly
amazing
ignorant backwards counterproductive and
yes
promoting support for an evil regime one
there's no right to peaceful
assembly in cuba that's what makes this
unprecedented people do not have the
right to get together and protest the
government why because it's a communist
dictatorship
second if you are trying to reduce this
down to covet policy
that is just incorrect it is wrong i
talked to many of the leaders of the
cuban dissident movement personally
not one of them mentioned coveted policy
as the chief rationale for what is going
on in cuba right now this is like
three weeks ago the the notion
that all of this is happening because of
lack of vaccinations in cuba
is nuts but trying to boil it down by
this is a way for the united states not
to have to take a position
on the evil of the cuban government
because the truth is that the biden
administration really has no idea what
to do with the cuban government
i mean as of march 80 u.s house
representative democrats were urging
biden to repeal trump's quote unquote
cruel sanctions on cuba and renew
engagement
right the idea being that if we if we
establish trade ties and
capitalism that this will somehow
moderate cuba weird because we've tried
that with
with china and all it's done is
strengthened the regime and created a
world historical opponent for the united
states
let's do the same thing with cuba makes
perfect sense let's uphold their regime
by ending the sanctions that have made
them economically weak and vulnerable to
protests like this
the fact that the united states has
remained largely silent
or that will melt a few platitudes about
the right to free assembly
without any sort of comprehensive
consequences
is pretty astonishing again this is a
tin pock dictatorship
it did the the fact that it's like north
korea on our border
and without a nuclear weapon and and we
do nothing
it really is quite wrong it is it is
quite despicable
in pretty much every way but it doesn't
matter because in the united states we
are too busy
beating up on ourselves we're too busy
talking about how terrible the united
states is again
you can talk about the flaws in the
united states and uphold freedom for
other places and acknowledge that the
united states is a beacon for freedom at
the same time but that is not what the
american left does the american left
does
not give a damn about the freedom of
people anywhere else on earth
in their perspective the noam chomsky
foreign policy perspective the united
states is a colonialist imperialist
power
and if we project freedom in other
places on earth
this makes us the villain we are bad
right we should we should just withdraw
and there's part and parcel of foreign
policy isolationism that is present on
the left
not out of a drive to preserve american
security
and not out of a drive to preserve
american resources but out of a drive
to undermine the basic fundamental
notion that the united states has been a
force for good in the world which
it undoubtedly has it undoubtedly has
in the united states failure to help
batista sufficiently defeat the cuban
regime led to a 60-year dictatorship
and we're seeing the consequences of it
right now
again it's it is remarkable to me that
the biden administration
can't joe biden can't be woken up from
his sunday nap to make a statement
about what is going on in cuba but
you'll have the same biden
administration talking about how we must
teach children
in school classrooms critical race
theory the notion that the united states
is not built on freedom the way that
cuban dissidents think it is or that
hong kong dissonance think it is or that
iranians think it is
no actually america is built on racism
and bigotry and homophobia
and cisgender patriarchy and all the
rest of this nonsense
it wasn't five minutes ago i mean
literally the end of the week last week
jen saki was saying to the white house
press corps that critical race theory
teaching in classrooms was an active
good
there is a connection between these two
things it is not a coincidence that the
same people who promote
teaching critical race theory have
nothing to say in defense of cuban
dissonance
that is not a coincidence at all it is
not a coincidence that the same people
who disdain the iranian dissidents and
the hong kong dissidents
that those people are the same people
who spend all their time talking about
how evil and terrible the united states
is
these are not folks who simply want a
better america these are folks who see
america as an act of evil and anywhere
we put our dirty grubby little fingers
the world gets worse in their
perspective
here is jen saki's take on critical race
theory being taught in america i'm glad
that we've put our focus here as opposed
to you know
projecting the most powerful economic
and military force the world has ever
seen
to to even a little bit like a drop just
to
help assure the liberty of of
freedom-seeking people
the president believes that in our
history uh there are many dark moments
and there is not just slavery and racism
in our history
there are systemic racism that is still
impacting society today
and he believes as i believe as a parent
of children
that kids should learn about our history
uh so as a
the spouse of an educator and as
somebody who is continues to believe
that children should learn uh not just
the good but also the challenging in our
history and that's part of what we're
talking about here even as it's become
politically
charged okay that is not what we are
talking about here that is a deliberate
misreading of the entire controversy of
our critical race theory which really is
about what america fundamentally is
people in the united states who believe
the american flag is fundamentally bad
because america is fundamentally bad
and it is not a coincidence that those
people are completely silent today as
cuban descendants
get clubbed in the streets we'll get
some more of this in just one second
first
let us talk about a simple fact if
you're a responsible person
you need things like home and auto
insurance do you not well policy genius
makes it easy to compare home and auto
insurance in one place they can help you
find home and auto coverage similar to
what you have now but at a lower price
they've saved customers an average of 1
250 bucks per year over what they were
paying for home and auto insurance
their team will handle the paperwork to
set up your new policy or switch over
your current one getting started is
super simple first
head on over to policygenius.com shapiro
home answer a few quick questions about
yourself and your property and then
policy genius will take it from there
they'll compare rates from america's top
insurers from progressive to allstate to
find
your lowest quotes the policy genius
team can look for ways to save you more
including bundling your home and auto
policies
if they find a better rate than what
you're paying right now they'll switch
you over for free
their top-notch service has earned
policy genius thousands of five star
reviews across trustpilot and google
head on over to policygenius.com
shapiro home to get started right now
again that's policygenius.com
shapiro home get started right now
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice and it is quite important to
get it right again policygenius.com
shapiro home to get started right now
policygenius.com
shapiro home alrighty so again what we
are watching in cuba is just a reminder
as hong kong was a reminder
that not only are there people who do
seek their liberty and see the united
states
as a symbol of that liberty but that
without
some level of american or foreign
support these people just get crushed
okay what we saw in hong kong was
massive protests millions of people in
the streets and then the chinese just
walked in
and decided they were going to make it
another principality of china in
violation of treaty and the west did
nothing and i have seven million people
who are living
under the open tyranny of the chinese
government and now you have china
threatening
taiwan as well as japan by extension by
the way the same thing
is likely to happen in cuba unless the
united states actually grows some stones
at a certain point and provides some
sort of credible threat to the cuban
government
with regard to protecting these
dissidents because the reality is that
the cuban government can go in and break
a few heads and then cuba won't be in
the headlines anymore and then everybody
in the united states will forget because
this is the way the united states says
foreign policy
when it comes to foreign policy
unfortunately the united states is not a
serious country we are
we are not interested in foreign policy
we find it to be something
unworthy of our time until it sort of
pops its head up
through some sort of deeply disturbing
foreign policy headline like the mass
slaughter of the yazidis in
in iraq for example or more or more
obviously a terrorist attack on an
american entity
when that sort of stuff happens we pay
attention to foreign policy for about
five seconds
and then we get bored and then we're
like okay well you know
should we do we really care about this
should we really care about this the
latest evidence of this of course
is what's going on in afghanistan where
boredom
ignorance and antipathy for america's
role in the world
have created this this vast confluence
which is leading to the united states
surrender in afghanistan which is
effectively what is going on right now
the united states is pulling out of
afghanistan for no discernible reason
there really is no discernable reason
when joe biden goes on national
television and he says things like
how many more american troops have to
die in afghanistan
this was a line that may have worked
like 10 years ago it should not have
worked any time in the past five or six
years considering the number of
americans who are actually dying in
afghanistan was lower than the number of
americans who were dying in chicago
pretty much every weekend except over
the course of a year
in afghanistan we were spending some
money to uphold the afghan government
yes it had corrupt serious corruption
problems yes there is serious tribalism
in afghanistan
but there was in fact a unified
government over the country of
afghanistan and now
for no apparent reason to no end we are
pulling out of afghanistan
and there are people who are celebrating
it not to for the life of me i can't
understand why
i do not understand why we are not at
the point in afghanistan
where crisis was upon us we were not at
the point where tens of thousands of
american troops were in harm's way or
hundreds of american troops were dying
or even tens of american troops were
dying and so the unilateral pullout is
meant
for only a couple of audiences one the
isolationist audience at home that
believes the united states really
shouldn't be involved anywhere in the
world that we are a deleterious force
in the world and two a bunch of people
who don't care about foreign policy
and anytime they see american troops
abroad get uncomfortable because they
don't really
understand that foreign policy is not a
vacuum and we are seeing full scale
foreign policy
is not a vacuum i mean the reality is
the taliban is going to retake the
country
and that is going to have some pretty
significant downstream effects yes for
the united states and yes for our allies
they're going to be downstream effects
because it turns out that when a regime
that you defeated 20 years ago in about
three weeks the taliban
when you defeat that regime and you
drive them to the hills and then you
establish a government and then you let
that government fall back to the
people you drove out you are
demonstrating that america is in fact a
paper tiger
that we are a also you are demonstrating
that we are a bad ally if you are a
freedom-seeking person how long are you
going to keep looking to the united
states if the united states no longer
backs you if you know at the minute the
american voter gets bored
there's gonna be a pull out and that you
are probably going to die and your
family is going to be killed along with
you
how many people are going to stand up
for freedom then how many people are
going to be willing
to stand up against the predations of
the taliban or against the iranian
how many times can the united states
over the course of the last 10
15 years screw our allies seriously
i'm just wondering how many times can we
screw our allies before people start to
say
you know what we got to work on our own
i'm talking about the kurds in iraq
i'm talking about yezidis in iraq i'm
talking about
the the anti-taliban forces amassed
in afghanistan i'm talking about the
people of hong kong how many times can
the west screw its allies before it has
no more allies
really serious question it's because
clearly our willingness to do pay any
price for freedom as john f kennedy once
famously suggested
is no longer there at least that is the
message from joe biden
the bite administration is openly
acknowledging at this point we're
handing the country back to the taliban
which by the way will provide a safe
haven once again for terrorism because
this is what they did
to begin here is the pentagon
spokesperson basically admitting to
chris wallace yeah you know the taliban
could take over
it's not the taliban could take over it
is only a matter of time until the
taliban take over
we're certainly watching with the deep
concern chris the deteriorating security
situation and the violence which is of
course way too high
and the advances and the momentum that
the taliban seems to have right now i
mean we're not
we're not unmindful of that chris we're
watching and monitoring it
which is why we are again working with
our afghan partners to encourage them to
use the capacity and the capability that
we know they have and we know
that they know how to defend their
country this is a time for them to step
up and to do exactly that
except that the taliban has taken back
one-third of the country without serious
combat
and everybody in foreign policy circles
knows that the taliban are likely to
topple the afghan government
almost immediately upon the exit of the
united states this has led to a rather
uncomfortable reality for the democrats
who are having to acknowledge that they
are
in fact engaging in the same sort of
pull-out in vietnam
that led to the imprisonment of millions
of people hundreds of thousands of
people floating in boats off the coast
of vietnam and the mil
in the murder of millions of people in
cambodia the democrats have a long
history of doing this sort of stuff
and it is never good in fact here is a
democrat
trying to suggest this is jack reed of
rhode island the senator
the chair of the armed services
committee trying to suggest that you
know what pulling out is the best of bad
options well
actually it isn't it isn't you know what
is the best of bad options
keeping a skeleton force in afghanistan
to prevent the takeover the taliban
that's actually the best of bad options
the united states currently has troops
in dozens of countries doing just that
and you know what that's all right
here's senator jack reed of rhode island
though basically saying that surrender
is the best of bad options
i think the president was presented with
a bad series of choices the trump
administration had said we were leaving
by may 1st
the taliban had no real uh
responsibilities in that agreement none
that they carried out that i can see
and yet that date i think would have
prompted an incredible increase of
violence and directed against the united
states so
i think the president made a difficult
but the best of
many poor choices oh really he actually
wasn't presented with the choices the
reality
he could have done whatever he wanted
just as presidents have done for decades
at this point
but underlying all of this is a
fundamental
lack of confidence in what the united
states is and what the united states
role
in the world is and that is a serious
problem because again there are people
out there who do not lack our confidence
i'm talking about china i'm talking
about russia i'm talking about iran
there's a reason why there's a headline
in the washington post today iran cheers
u.s withdrawal
from afghanistan yes i i know why i've
noticed
tehran is is worried about the taliban
because afghanistan returning to civil
war
afghanistan your remember is on iran's
border and so this creates some external
effects
for iran but iran has cultivated ties
with some taliban factions and softened
its tone toward the extremist group
that gamble has elicited fierce debate
in iran supposedly
iran's increasingly public overtures to
the taliban
continue one of the experts over there
says iran believes they are using the
taliban some could argue the taliban is
using iran to present themselves
as more powerful and worthy of ruling a
country
the taliban thought to control around a
third of afghanistan has so far largely
gained ground without full-scale
fighting has instead relied on cutting
deals
with local leaders and the reason they
can do that is because there is no
counterweight in the region there is no
counterweight
meanwhile in recent weeks iranian
hardliners aligned with iran's supreme
leader ayatollah ali khamenei
and president-elect ibrahim reisi who
himself is a terrorist mass murderer
have gone on the offensive and publicly
painted a rose-tinted
picture of a changed taliban so it is it
is just wonderful
to see how the united states is
complicit in all of this we've now
pulled out of afghanistan in order to
facilitate the rise of the taliban we
are openly making overtures to an
iranian regime that rigged an election
on behalf of a mass murdering terrorist
we have allowed hong kong to fall to the
chinese and
if pattern holds we'll do very little as
cuban dissidents are clubbed into
submission on the streets of cuba
of havana um
america is going to need to figure out
exactly what it is if we wish to be a
beacon of liberty in the world
but given that the united states is own
citizenry at least half of them
apparently believe the united states is
not even a beacon of liberty inside its
own borders
there's a fundamental lack of confidence
that is setting in
and the world is not going to be better
off for that americans aren't going to
be better off for that because there are
malign influences in the world at work
the united states is not going to have a
better future if
vicious totalitarian powers gain power
internationally
and inside the united states those who
seek to tear down the fundamental
institutions of freedom
are successful here none of that is
going to be good for american citizens
or
for human beings the world over because
let's face it the radical increase in
prosperity and freedom that has occurred
since the end of world war ii
is almost solely due to the massive
power and influence of the united states
a confident united states be striding
the world stage when that ends
so does all of the wealth so does all
the prosperity and so does all of the
freedom can go right back to what things
were before the united states was the
most prosperous and powerful force
on planet earth already coming up the
new york times apparently has noticed
that the
that joe biden is in a running gun
battle with his teleprompter and kamala
harris
is no substitute for a real candidate
we'll get to that in just one second
first
let us talk about the kind of chair you
use at the office so you're probably
sitting in like a normal office chair
right now you're thinking something
that's this isn't so bad
and then you get up later you're like oh
my bad what happened it's your office
chair get a better chair i'm talking
about the best chair
the chair of champions i'm talking about
x-chair x-char has you covered
for your office chair needs the extra
can give you a massage while you're
sitting at your desk it can warm your
back on cold mornings and can cool you
off on hot days
the secret is not only their patented
dynamic variable lumbar support which
offers unbelievable lumbar supports your
lower back
now they've introduced lmx featuring
cooling heat and massage therapy
imagine regulating your body temperature
and getting massage therapy while
sitting at your desk
extra lmx cooling delivers heat and
massage technology directly to your core
helping to increase blood flow
muscle recovery and energy these are all
perks that make working from home or the
office a joy
lmax even offers four different massage
modes and fast warming heat technology
for therapy to your sore back extra
prices are going to go up on july 12th
that is today for the first time in two
years so you need to get it like now
like right right now go to
xchairshapiro.com now that's the letter
x
chair shapiro shapiro.com or call one
eight four four four x chairs get a
hundred bucks off your order
extra has a 30-day guarantee of complete
comfort you can finance your purchase
for as little as 30 bucks a month go to
xchairshapiro.com now
use codexwheels for free xwheel
bladecasters xchairshapiro.com
go check them out right now alrighty
whether it is totalitarian lockdown
measures that destroyed the middle class
while big business thrived or
the blatant indoctrination of school
children into critical race theory
there's no denying the freedom of
everyday americans is under assault
and you can tell it's gone too far when
just questioning the mainstream
narrative inspires fear of retribution
and creates waves of silence where
otherwise there would be descent
you feel it at your job you feel it in
good school you feel it every time you
go into a store these days
we are living through an authoritarian
moment which is why i wrote the book
the authoritarian moment to help people
like you learn as much about how he got
there
as you can and more importantly how you
can fight back like we all feel it we
all feel like we are swimming
in a in a miasma of totalitarian
thought right now it feels like if you
say the wrong thing on facebook you're
going to be excised from your social
circles it feels like if you say the
wrong thing
in an email you're going to get fired it
feels like if you just express
a basic opinion about the goodness of
america you may find yourself on the
social outs
and you have all the most powerful
institutions of society weaponized
against you
this is what the authoritarian moment is
all about the left has suggested that
people on the right are the
totalitarians there are certainly
totalitarians on the far right
but the great threat to the united
states right now is
the mainstream left which has imbibed
from the authoritarian well
and sees itself as a utopian group
capable of cramming down
on you all of their own ideas
my book the authoritarian moment is
about how all of our major institutions
from science to
to tech to to movies to
your kid's school got taken over by the
authoritarian left and
again more importantly how to fight back
with real strategies the authoritarian
moment is now available for pre-order at
amazon barnes and noble or any other
major bookseller you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
meanwhile joe biden continues to be in a
running gun battle with his teleprompter
it is not going well even the new york
times has now noticed this
according to the new york times even the
president labeled a speech boring
recently in a mission that highlights a
tendency towards delivering
minutia-filled discourse over scaling
or rhetorical heights i love how they
they really have to obscure even their
own message
voters chose boring over bombast they
got biden's pension for pontificating
according to michael
shear even president biden thought he
had been ponderous i know it's a boring
speech the 46th president said at the
end of 31 minutes and 19 seconds filled
with statistics
academic studies global growth domestic
product comparisons and predictions of
7.4
economic growth the president's remarks
on wednesday delivered to a friendly and
respectful crowd of supporters
at mchenry county college in the chicago
suburb even included reconciliation
which mr biden quickly admitted was a
fancy
washington word as the president travels
the country pitching his plan for
spending trillions of dollars to reshape
the american economy
he is facing a rhetorical reality that
has long plagued many of his
predecessors there is a vast difference
between explaining
and inspiring and mr biden who has
recently called the explainer in chief
by his press secretary
often struggles to reach the potential
oratorical heights of the office he
holds
mr biden's ambitions are vast the
substance of his presidency has been
dramatic
at times he sometimes describes his
agenda as a way to prove that the very
concept of democracy itself can deliver
for the people the white house is
perfectly fine with mr biden's ability
to turn down the political heat in
washington after four years of chaotic
governance but like
former president barack obama once
delivered a 17-minute answer to health
care question
and bill clinton was forced to apologize
to a late night comic for a dreadful
convention speech mr biden can sometimes
get lost in the minutia
okay i love how the new york times is
framing this joe biden cannot string
together a sentence
off teleprompter when he is on
teleprompter he is in a running battle
with the teleprompter and the new york
times frames that says he's too much of
an expert
he's just too with it guys it's not that
joe biden is
entering the early stages of dementia it
is that joe biden is just
so unbelievably with it he is so into
all of the minute details of his own
policy proposals he can send you a
chapter
and verse he'll bore you to tears with
all of the minutia you've noticed by the
way i love that paragraph
barack obama that man was just a policy
wonk just so wonky
bill clinton's so unbelievably wonky i'm
noticing you're leaving out like a few
presidents that happen between here they
all have ours by their names
because it turns out according to the
media every republican is an idiot
dunderhead who can't speak a sentence
and every democrat is world
beatingly genius just brilliant you'll
remember they made the same excuse about
al gore
al gore was unbelievably boring a
terrible speaker
no charisma and their excuse for why he
lost to george w bush is of course that
al gore was too smart for the room
they said the same thing about john
kerry in 2004. john kerry has never been
in a room where he was too smart for the
room he has not been in a first grade
classroom
as an adult where he was too smart for
the room
and john kerry is one of the stupidest
people alive and yet according to the
new york times and according to the rest
of the media the big problem for every
democrat incapable of properly
communicating
is of course that they are just too
brilliant for the room well one of the
other people who is obviously too
brilliant for the room
is kamala harris right the reason that
kamala harris is having her political
struggles right now
is clearly because kamala harris is just
so smart she's just so she's smarter
than you
that's why and you may be looking at her
and watching her on tv and thinking to
yourself
this lady is not super bright like she
says
lots of dumb crap routinely you might i
know you might be thinking that to
yourself
and then you should but you should know
it's you
it's not her it's you so like for
example
over the weekend when she did an
interview with uh bet
in which she um explained that voter id
is racist
because rural people can't get
photocopies
that's all that's just because she's
smart it's not because she's dumb or out
of touch
or doesn't or or a time traveler from
1971 it's because
she's actually just so brilliant it's
your fault
it's like all the conversations that
that the media critics now have
about hollywood whenever a crowd doesn't
like a particular movie or an aspect of
a particular movie that the media want
them to like
is that the crowd is filled with toxic
fandom and whenever people are like
yeah you know wasn't so into that that
that character from last jedi
i didn't really like that and they're
like toxic fandom
people weren't into lady ghostbusters a
lot of toxic it's the same thing about
democrats if you don't like a democrat
it's you
it is not it's principal skinner from
from the simpsons
it's not me it's the children who are
the problem it's not it's not kamala
harris it's you who are the problem
so listen to the world breaking genius
of our vice president of the united
states who is based
who was selected largely and almost only
on the basis of her intersectional
qualifications here she was
demonstrating her full-scale genius
in some people's mind that means well
you're going to have to
um xerox are
photocopy your idea to send it in to
proof you are who you are
well there are a whole lot of people
especially people who live in rural
communities who don't there's no
kinko's there's no office max near them
people have to understand that when
we're talking about voter id laws
be clear about who you have in mind and
what would be required of them to prove
who they are
um what so
here's the thing photocopiers were
invented in the united states in the
1930s
they were widely available pretty much
everywhere by the 1970s so unless she's
a time traveler from 1971 i don't know
what the hell she is talking about also
when is the last time you actually used
a photocopier you have a printer at your
house
i assume because most people have
printers at their house rural or urban
also you don't even have to print crap
now
all you have to do is take a picture of
something and you can email it to
somebody to print it out for you
or you could just do a scan directly
from your phone
if you got an iphone all you got to do
is go to your notes section
i mean to guide you through how to how
to actually scan a pdf on your phone but
you can just do it
okay but apparently com world breaking
genius it's all world breaking genius
you know it is this sort of coverage
that i think leads people to a radical
level of institutional distrust
a radical level of distrust of media
and this has some predictable effect
andrew sullivan has a really
good and interesting piece over at his
sub stack about how he has been
disconnected from the left
how the institutional left has basically
moved beyond the populace
his peace and sullivan again is uh is
a center left figure he's sort of
right-wing on foreign policy a little
bit during the bush years in the early
years of bush
but aside from that andrew sullivan is a
is a very openly
gay man uh he was he was a very early
advocate of gay marriage
andrew sullivan is also the guy who
suggested that that trigg palin
was not in fact sarah palin's child
right andrew sullivan's left-wing
bonafides were pretty much in order
until the last five minutes there's a
piece
on substance called what happened to you
he says what happened to you that's a
question i get a lot on twitter
when did you become so far right why
have you become a white supremacist
transphobic misogynistic eugenist
or a eugenicist or of course see i told
you who he really was
just take off the hood sully it's
trolling mainly and it's a weapon for
some in the elite to wield against
others
in the emotional kind of blackmail
spiral that was first pioneered on elite
college campuses
but it's worth answering a year after i
was booted from new york magazine for my
unacceptable politics because it seems
to me
that the dynamic really should be the
other way around the real question is
what happened to you
the critical race theory debate is just
the latest squall and tempest brewing
and building for five years or so
and yes some of the liberal critiques of
a fox news hype campaign are well taken
is this a wedge issue for the gop of
course it is are they using the term
critical race theory as a cynical
marketing boogeyman of course they are
are some dog whistles involved a few are
crude bans on public servants
speech dangerous absolutely but does
that mean there isn't a real issue here
of course it doesn't take a big step
back observe what has happened in our
discourse since around 2015. forget crt
for a moment ask yourself
is nothing going on here but republican
propaganda and guile can you not see
that the republicans may be acting but
they are also reacting
reacting against something that is right
in front of our noses what is it
it is says andrew sullivan i'd argue the
sudden rapid stunning shift in the
belief system of the american elites
it has sent the whole society into a
profound cultural dislocation
it is in essence an ongoing moral panic
against the specter of white supremacy
which is now bizarrely regarded as an
accurate description of the largest
freest most successful multi-racial
democracy in human history
we all know it's happened the elite
increasingly sequestered within one
political party and one media
monoculture educated by colleges and
private schools
that have become hermetically sealed
against any non-left ascent have had a
quote social justice reckoning these
past few years
and they have been ideologically
transformed with countless cascading
consequences
take it from a woke new york times star
kara swisher
who celebrated this week that quote the
country's social justice movement
is reshaping how we talk about well
everything
she's right and certainly about the new
york times and all mainstream journalism
this is the media hub of the social
justice movement and the core point of
that movement its essential point is
that liberalism is no longer enough
not just not enough but itself it means
to perpetuate white supremacy
designed to oppress harm and terrorize
minorities and women an entire need of
dismantling
that's a huge deal and it explains a lot
a specter
of invisible and unfalsifiable systems
and structures and internal biases
arrived to hover around the world some
of this critique was specific and
helpful
the legacy of redlining the depth of the
wealth gap but much was tendentious
post-modern theorizing
popular breakthrough was tanahasi
coates's essay on reparations in the
atlantic and his subsequent
gut-wrenching memoir between the world
and me he combined the worldview and
vocabulary of critical race theory with
the vivid lived experience of his own
biography
he's a beautifully gifted writer i'm not
surprised he had such an emotional
impact
even if in my view the power of his
prose blinded many to the radical
implement
implications of the ideology he
surrendered to and what many of his blog
readers called
his blue period the movement is much
broader than race as anyone who's
dealing with matters of sex and gender
will tell you
the best moniker i've read to describe
this mismatched uh this mishmash of
postmodern thought and therapy culture
ascendant among liberal white elites is
wesley yang's coinage the successor
ideology
the structural oppression is white
supremacy but it can be also expressed
more broadly
to describe a hegemony that is saturated
with anti-blackness misogyny transphobia
and a miasma of social cis
heteronormative patriarchal white
supremacy
and the term successor ideology works
because it centers the fact that this
ideology wishes first and foremost first
and foremost
to repeal and succeed a liberal society
and democracy
and this is in this successor ideology
there's no escape no refuge from the
ongoing nightmare of oppression and
violence you're either fighting this and
on the right side of history or you're
against it
and abating evil there is no neutrality
that is the world the left is building
for you and that is why
you are right to lie about kamal
harris's wild qualifications and joe
biden fighting his teleprompter
it is why you are correct to ignore
dissidents in hong kong and cuba as they
fly the american flag and instead rip on
the american flag because it represents
systems
and structures of oppression this is in
fact a great ideological battle of our
time
and it's going to continue it is not
slowing down anytime soon
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content in
the meantime
go check out the michael moles show
today he discusses chicago's decision to
provide free condoms to all students
ages 10 and up oh goody
you can hear more details about this
story over on michael's show that's
available right now i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo widowski
associate producer bradford carrington
host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is by fabiola
cristina production assistant jessica
kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
prominent leftists label all whites
racist
the feds harass more conservatives and
chicago gives condoms to 10 year olds
check it out on the michael knowles show